what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm your host
Warren Thompson and Deadpool 3 has fans
super super excited about what we could
possibly see in the movie we already
know it's going to be absolutely bonkers
the writers have already talked about
how chaotic it is going to be having
Deadpool in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and Ryan Reynolds himself has
basically confirmed some pretty big plot
points of what to expect from Deadpool
3. but today we have some big news about
one huge plot point that we'll see in
Deadpool 3 that is going to have a
pretty big impact not only on the movie
but the MCU as a whole and we've learned
that Mobius from Loki Owen Wilson's
Mobius is going to be appearing in
Deadpool 3 and is going to actually have
a major role in the film and this is
awesome we can never get enough Mobius
maybe he'll even write a jet ski in
Deadpool 3. have you had a jet ski
they'll most likely save that for some
type of a finale for Loki season 2 or
season three or maybe Secret Wars but if
there is any character that can poke fun
at Mobius and talk about riding a jet
ski and tease him for it it is
definitely Deadpool so in this video
we're going to talk about how exactly
Mobius will be in Deadpool 3 what we can
expect from that plot and also the plot
that Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman have
teased us with and how this will affect
the MCU and of course if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe and hit
the notification Bell so you don't miss
out on any of the latest videos so
Mobius is going to be in Deadpool 3 and
he's going to play a major role in the
movie this report is coming from Daniel
rpk's patreon account his report
specifically says Owen Wilson will have
a big role in Deadpool 3. he will
reprise his role as Mobius from Loki now
if we think about this this just makes
sense we know that Deadpool is going to
be going from the fox Universe into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe and it's kind
of mobius's sole job and purpose to make
sure that people don't actually jump
timelines in the sacred timeline isn't
compromised and no new timelines Branch
out but of course the big question is if
Mobius is still hunting people down when
exactly is Deadpool 3 going to take
place because at the end of Loki season
1 the Mobius that we met in new and kind
of fell in love with throughout the
entire season one of Loki was kind of
reset by the events that took place in
the finale Mobius had no idea who Loki
was at the very end so which Mobius
exactly is going to be kind of hunting
down Deadpool well logic would tell us
that it's the Mobius before he kind of
got reset and the reason why we think
that is because of what Ryan Reynolds
and Hugh Jackman said when they did a
video talking to the fans about kind of
what to expect from Deadpool 3 and
spoiler alert if you haven't seen Logan
yet about to drop some pretty big
spoilers for that movie also if you
haven't seen it go see it but Ryan and
Hugh they specifically told us that
they're not going to essentially unkill
Logan they're not going to change the
fact that he died in Logan which means
Deadpool is going to have to pull Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine out of some point in
time before that now at the end of
Deadpool 2 in the post-credits we kind
of saw Deadpool doing that already he
did what he called cleaning up the
timeline hey it's me don't scratch
cleaning up the timelines look
eventually you're gonna hang up the
claws and it's going to make a lot of
people very sad huh but one day your old
pal Wade's gonna ask you to get back in
the saddle again
and when he does say yes so Deadpool has
already begun to mess up time so this is
the first we'll call it offense and the
tva's eyes that Deadpool has committed
so right away right here the TV8 is
going to be after Deadpool however we
know that he's going to go to the MCU
and we know that before he gets to the
MCU he's going to stop by a lot of other
different universes and like I mentioned
before Ryan Reynolds has pretty much
already told us the plot of Deadpool 3
because he's kind of had the plot idea
for a pretty long time even before the
Disney Foxdale went down in fact in a
tweet that he put out on January 28th of
2021 he said before Disney bought Fox
Deadpool 3 was gonna be a road trip
between Deadpool and Logan rashamon
style for real now rashaman was a 1950
psychological thriller movie the movie
is about the murder of a samurai told by
different people and each of them have
slightly different perspectives of what
exactly happened so essentially Deadpool
3 is going to be the story of a giant
multiversal road trip between Logan and
Deadpool and each of them kind of
telling different stories about what
exactly happened so what exactly does
this mean how does Mobius fit into the
picture and how does this end we'll talk
about that in just a bit but first big
thank you to wondery and the official
Lord of the Rings podcast for sponsoring
this video now I know a lot of you like
me have watched The Lord of the Rings
the rings of power on Amazon it's
amazing I loved it and since you're on
my Channel right now you probably love
to dive even deeper than just watching
the show and now you can go deeper into
the canals of numenor the minds of
kazadum and more with the official the
Lord of the Rings rings of power podcast
host Felicia Day who many people
probably know and several special guests
provide an inside look at the
groundbreaking series and what it took
to bring Middle Earth to life each
episode of the official podcast features
exclusive interviews with the series
showrunner DJ Payne and Patrick McKay
including the very first full breakdown
of the incredible season finale Felicia
also goes behind the scenes with the
cast and crew to bring you jaw-dropping
stories and Easter eggs you won't want
to miss watch the rings of power on
Prime video and listen to all eight
episodes of the official the Lord of the
Rings the rings of power podcast for
free on Amazon music download the Amazon
music app right now to listen to The
Lord of the Rings the rings of power
podcast so Logan and Deadpool are going
to travel across the Multiverse until
they eventually get their way to the MCU
however they're going to have Mobius and
the TVA on their backs now obviously we
know that Deadpool 3 is a comedy a very
clever a very raunchy comedy and the
fact that Mobius and the TVA are going
to be involved in Deadpool 3 not only
makes sense as far as continuity is
concerned in the actual Marvel Cinematic
Universe but it's also pretty dang
brilliant because now you can actually
directly connect Deadpool to the events
of Secret Wars obviously Deadpool 3 is
just going to be sort of the
introduction of Deadpool into the MCU in
fact it's probably safe to assume that a
good majority of the film isn't going to
take place in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe but the good majority of the
film will be that road trip between
Deadpool and Wolverine going to
different universes as Mobius and the
TVA try to track him down and here's the
thing about that Wolverine and Deadpool
are extremely good Fighters and both can
be extremely intense so I don't think
the TVA really kind of has a chance
against them so that makes you wonder
how exactly Mobius is going to approach
them is he going to approach them with
Force at first sending TVA troops in to
try and prune them he might do that at
first but I'm sure he'll learn pretty
quickly that Deadpool and Wolverine
don't go down without a fight in fact
they really kind of don't go down at all
I mean Colossus ripped Deadpool's body
in half and he was still alive and he
grew back the lower part of his body and
of course Wolverine can heal as well so
it kind of makes you wonder what the TVA
could really do against them so Mobius
might actually take more of a calm
talking approach sort of like he did
with Loki more along the lines of trying
to reason with them probably trying to
reason with Wolverine if we're being
honest since he's a little bit less
sarcastic
but this is going to be kind of like a
buddy cop film Wolverine and Deadpool
are going to be buddies so Wolverine's
not gonna go for this either now it's
unclear if the TVA is going to be the
villains of this in fact I'm sure they
won't be I'm sure they'll just be a
really good part that's added to this
movie to kind of give it continuity in
the MCU as far as the sacred timeline is
concerned the Multiverse is concerned
and incursions and Secret Wars like I
said this brings Deadpool into Avengers
Secret Wars because let's face it
Deadpool is chaotic he's a mess and he
doesn't really care about too much the
things he does care about he really
cares about but I'm sure he doesn't
really care about causing incursions so
I'm sure that by the time he actually
gets to the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he's probably going to have caused some
incursions to happen but I am assuming
that by the time that he actually does
get to the MCU this will pretty much be
right around the time that Sylvie kills
he who remains and the Multiverse is
completely burst open or it could even
be after that takes place if Deadpool is
traveling to different universes that
could be because the sacred time line
has already burst open it really depends
on how they explain time travel in
Deadpool 3 and how they Explain the
ending of Loki we'll learn more about
that in Loki season 2. it could be that
every Universe in the Multiverse has its
own sacred timeline or it could be that
the sacred timeline was one universe and
the branches are now many different
other universes again that is something
we'll have to wait and see about but one
thing I do know is I love Owen Wilson
and I loved his character Mobius and I
think he's going to add a really good
not only story to Deadpool 3 but also a
lot of really great humor as well I'm
really excited to see Owen Wilson and
Ryan Reynolds interact in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but let me know how
excited you are about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on all things MCU for live updates
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter and as always thank you all so
much for watching wolf wolf